[Musique]
plus temps que régnait le grand pan les
dieux protégés les ivrognes un tas de gé
ti tubant au nez rouge à la rouge trogne
les canom vidait les cruchons qu'un sac
à vin faisait carousse il venait en
bande à ses trouss conter les bouchons
la plus humble piquette était alors
bénie distilé par Noë ven et compagnie
le vin donnait un lustre au pire des
minus et le moindre pochar avait tout de
Bacus mais se touchant le crâne en
criant j'ai trouvé la bande au
professeur Nimbus est arrivé qui s'est m
à frapper les cieux d'alignement chasser
les dieux du FIR
maman aujourd'hui ça là les les gens
boivent encore et le feu du nectar fait
toujours luir les trognes mais les
diunes répondent plus pour les ivrognes
Bacus est alcoolique et le grandpan est
mort quand de imbéciles heureux
s'amusaient à des bagatelles un tas de
géis amoureux venaient leur tenir la
chandelle du fin fond les Champs Élysées
dès qu'ils entendaient un je tame ils
accouraient à l'in même compter les
baiser la plus humble amourette était
alors bénie sacré paraphrodite héros et
compagnie l'amour donnait un lustre au
pire des minus et la moindre amoureuse
avait tout de Vénus mais se touchant le
crâne en criant j'ai trouvé la bande au
professeur Nimbus est arrivé qui s'est
mise à frapper les cieux d'alignement
chasser les dieux du FIR
maman aujourd'hui ça et là les cœurs
battent encore et la règle du jeu de
l'amour est la même mais les dieux ne
répondent plus de ceux qui s'aiment
Vénus est faite femme et le grand Pan
est mort et quand fatal son est l'heure
de mettre en l'un seul pour costume un
tas de G l'œil en pleur vous offrait les
honneurs postumes pour aller au Céleste
Empire dans leur bar qu'il venaient vous
prendre c'était presque un plaisir de
rendre le dernier soupire la plus humble
despouilles était alors
bénie embarqué par Caron Pluton et
compagnie au pire des minus l'âme était
accordé et le moindre mortel avait
l'éternité mais se touchant le crâne en
criant j'ai trouvé la bande au
professeur Nimbus est arrivé qui s'est
mis à frapper les cieux
d'alignement chasser les dieux du FIR
maman aujourd'hui ça est là les gens
passent encore mais la tombe est hélas
la dernière de Meur et les dieux ne
répondent plus de ceux qui meurent la
mort est naturel et le grand P est mort
et l'un des derniers dieux l'un des
derniers suprêmes ne doit plus se sentir
tellement bien lui-même un beau jour on
va voir le
Christ descendre du calvaire en disant
dans salpe merde je ne joue plus pour
tous ces pauvres ti j'ai bien peur que
la fin du monde soit bien
triste